politicians and the media have focused
on Muslims Islam and Muslim communities
but our communities have been left out
not anymore this campaign is a
motivational opportunity that engages
American Muslims to say no longer will
the selection be about us without us
that we will speak up we will
participate in multiple ways and we'll
make sure that if it's going to be about
us it's going to be with us you want
people to see us as a progressive
community that stands for the rights and
and demand justice for all people and we
hope this campaign will reflect that by
hearing the stories and the issues that
diverse American Muslims across the
countries care about and want to work
towards